When using an application, there's
usually some type of authentication
required. We have to put in a username,
a password, and all of the data that
we're viewing is specific for our login.
But what if an attacker was able to
inject their own code into the
communication going back and forth to
the server and somehow circumvent this
authentication process to gain access to
all of the data that's in the database.
One of the common techniques for this
type of attack is a SQL injection. Most
of the time, an application should be
doing some type of validation of the
input and making sure that nothing
malicious is making its way into the
application itself. But if an
application developer is not spending a
lot of time on input validation or
they're not doing any type of
validation, this might leave this
application susceptible to a SQL
injection attack. This is not the only
type of data that could be injected to
gain access to the internals of an
application. An attacker might use HTML,
XML, LDAP, or any number of methods to
be able to circumvent the security
features of that app.
SQL or SQL is the structured query
language. This is a very common language
used to access information contained in
a relational database. If you're using
MySQL, Microsoft SQL Server, or any
number of SQLbased databases, they will
all use a similar language to access
that data. A SQL injection allows us to
put our own SQL queries into this
application. This is something that
should never occur, but because of the
way the application is built, it allows
us to circumvent the security and gain
immediate access to all of that database
information. The reason that we have a
username, password, or some type of
authentication is to protect this data
in the database. A SQL injection
bypasses all of those protections and
effectively gives someone full access to
all of the data in that system.
If we were to look at an application,
you might be able to find some SQL code
in the application itself. And I have an
example here which is select asterisk
from users where name equals and then a
variable is installed there as username.
This means that we're going to select
information that is in a database. We're
going to select everything from a table
named users and we're looking for a
specific username in this example and
it's the name that is contained within
that variable as part of the
application. If we were to see this in
use, the actual query would look
something like this. Select asterisk
from users where name equals professor.
That is a very common SQL query and it's
one that is going to request the
database to provide all of the records
where the username equals the word
professor. What we're going to do is to
inject our own code into this query. In
this case, we're injecting everything
that's listed here in purple. So instead
of having this select command the way it
was, we're going to add additional
information onto this select command,
specifically an apostrophe, the word or
and apostrophe 1 apostrophe equals
apostrophe 1. This jumble of apostrophes
and letters and numbers changes this
query. So instead of simply looking for
one username called professor, we're
looking for any username called
professor or anywhere where the number
one might equal the number one.
Obviously the number one does equal the
number one, which means this part of the
query means that we're going to look for
any name that might be in the database
and return that information to the user.
Even if the user does not have access to
other parts of the database, this little
bit of injected data effectively
circumvents any type of security that
may already exist. That single bit of
injected code now gives the attacker
full access to the database where they
can view the data, modify the data, or
delete data from that database.
Let's try SQL injection into an
application that has intentionally been
written to be susceptible to a SQL
injection. This is an exercise within
web goat which is an intentionally
vulnerable set of applications and
examples. In this example, there is an
input for an employee name and an
authentication access number. This code
is one that is very similar to a
password. Normally, we would type in our
username and the authentication TAN. The
username and the TAN that would be used
for normal user are listed here on the
screen. So the username is Smith and the
TAN is 3SL99A.
This is the normal username and password
someone might use to gain access to this
application. And if we submit that, we
can see that we are logged in with that
username. And we can see their user ID,
the department associated with this
user, their salary, and of course you
can see their authentication information
as well. But the attacker doesn't want
access to this single user's data. They
want access to all data inside of this
system. So, let's reset this page. I'm
going to refresh it. So, we're back to
where we started. And now we can see
that we can put in our SQL injection
right here on this employee name line.
We're not using a legitimate employee
name. We're not putting in a password.
We're simply putting in apostrophe or 1=
1 semicolon dash. And if we choose the
option to get that department, it lists
out all of the records in this database.
So we can see all of the user IDs,
everyone's name, the department that
they're in, and we can see the salary
for everybody in the organization along
with the authentication information for
each one of these usernames. Obviously,
this information should not be
accessible to us. But because we were
able to successfully use a SQL
injection, we circumvented all the
security and gained full access to the
database.